let's say that we have an exponential
function h of n and since it's an
exponential function it's going to be
the form a times r to the n where a is
our initial value and r is our common
ratio and we're going to assume that r
is greater than 0. and they've given us
some information on h of n we know that
when n is equal to 2 h of 2 is 144 that
h of 4 is 324 that h of 6 is 729
so based on the information here let's
see if we can actually figure out what a
and r are going to be
and like always pause the video and try
to give it a go
all right now let's let's do this
together so i'm going to focus on r
first
the common
ratio
and if we had successive ends if we had
h of 3 then we could just find the ratio
between h of 3 and h of 2 and r would
just come out of that or if the ratio
between h of 4 and h of 3 we could solve
explicitly for r but we can get pretty
close to that we can just find the ratio
between h of 4 and h of 2. so h of 4 the
ratio between h of 4
and h of 2
is going to be equal to
well we know h of 4 is 324
and h of 2 is 144
and we could simplify this a little bit
let's see if we
if we simplify this we would get they're
both divisible by 2. if we divide them
both by 2 this one in the numerator 324
divided by 2 is 1
62. 144 divided by 2 is 72.
let's see if we can divide by 2 again 81
over 36.
divide by 2. actually no we can't divide
by 2 anymore but we can divide by 9 now
so 81 divided by 9 is 9 and 36 divided
by 9 is 4. so this thing can be
rewritten as 9 4. but we could also
rewrite this ratio by using
using this this form of an exponential
function so we could also say that this
is going to be equal to h of 4 is going
to be a
times r now n is 4 so r to the 4th power
and h of two is going to be a times r to
the second power
a times r to the second power
and this simplifies nicely a divided by
a cancel is just one and then r to the
fourth divided by r squared
well that's going to be r to the 4 minus
2 power or r it's going to be r to the
second power it's going to be r squared
and so we have a nice little equation
set up r squared
needs to be equal to
9 4. so let me write that down r squared
is equal to 9 4.
and r needs to be greater than 0 so we
could just say r is going to be the
principal root
of 9 4 which is equal to 3 halves so we
were able to figure out r
so now how do we figure out how do we
figure out a
well there's a couple of ways to do it
you can think about
a is going to be what h of 0 is equal to
so we could do what i could i guess we
could call a tabular method
where let me set up
a little table here
so
a little table so if this is n
and this is h of n
so n is 0 we don't know what h of 0 is
just yet it's going to be a
we don't know what h of 1 is yet
we do know that h of 2 is 144
and we do know since the common ratio is
3 halves if we take h of 1 and we
multiply it by three halves
we're going to get h of two and if we
take h of zero and multiply it by three
halves we're gonna get h of one
so h of one is going to be 144 divided
by three halves so let's write that down
h of 1 is equal to 144 divided by
3 halves
which is going to be 144
144 times 2 over 3
and let's see 144
divided by 3
is going to be equal to
is it
let's see 1 3 goes into i'll just do
this by hand my brain doesn't work that
well while i'm making videos 3 goes into
14
4 times 4 times 3 is 12 subtract so it's
going to be i see it's going to be 48 3
goes into 24 8 times 8 times 3 is 24 you
have no remainder
so
this is going to be 48 times
2 which is going to be equal to 96 so
this is going to be 96 and so if we want
to figure out h of 0 we just divide by 3
halves again
so h of 0
is 96
divided by
3 halves which is equal to 96 times 2
over 3.
96 divided by 3 let's see it's going to
be 32 so this is going to be 30
32
times did i do that right yep 32 times 2
which is equal to 64.
64. and so just like that we figured out
that a is equal to 64 and r
and r is equal to three halves so we can
write h of n
we can say that h of n
is equal to 64
is equal to
64
times three halves
times three halves our common ratio
to the nth power
now there's another way that we could
have tackled this instead of this
tabular method we could have just solved
for a now since we know r we know for
example
we know for example that h
of 2
which is going to be equal to a times we
know what our common ratio is it's 3
halves
to the second power
is going to be equal to 144
and so we could say a times 9 over 4 is
equal to 144
and so we can multiply both sides times
the reciprocal of 9 over 4 so we
multiply both sides times 4 over 9
times 4 over 9.
that cancels with that that cancels with
that
and we are left with
a is equal to
let's see 144 divided by 9
is going to be
is going to be i want to say it's equal
to
16
is is that
right
i think that is right yep and then 16
times 4 so this is going to be 16
and 1. 16 times 4 is
64 which is exactly what we got before
and so this actually this method now
that i look at it is actually
a good bit easier but they're equivalent
and i like this one because you get to
see the common ratio in action and you
get to see that the initial value is the
initial value it is h of zero but either
way once you figure out r you and you
know one of the uh h of you know what
the function is at a value you can solve
for a and frankly if you knew a and you
knew what the function was for given n
you could likewise solve for r so
hopefully you enjoyed that